foreign
what's going on in West Virginia Debbie
hello thank you for taking my call
you're welcome
um about about a year ago maybe a year
and a half ago I bought a car for my son
I co-signed for a car it was a 2017
Veloster Turbo okay and he drove it for
about uh eight months making the
payments he has a good job and he goes
to work every day so I was proud of him
for that he makes good money okay and um
apparently he didn't have the credit so
they flipped it around and put it in my
name and put him underneath me I didn't
know that though so meanwhile on the way
to vacation
his transmission goes out
and he's not with me so they tow it off
and they told him it's going to be nine
thousand dollars to fix it and it has
under a hundred thousand miles on it
okay so it ends up that they said we
didn't have any warranty but it ends up
I had it towed back to home and they
said yes you do have warranty on it and
the transmission can be replaced but so
it was in limbo for like four or five
months without being fixed because it
took them forever to get it done okay
then during that time my son lost his
license how did that happen
uh long distance driving to a girlfriend
and he got tickets for speeding on the
interstate
license okay how old is your son Debbie
well
and he's 21. okay now okay so you spend
the 9k to fix the transmission
right it didn't cost me anything it
ended up being free but the warranty
okay paid eight I paid 18 for the car we
still owe 15 and he really can't drive
the car because he doesn't have license
is he still working I don't
yes he is okay so where's the how can I
help you today
well um
when you lose your license your
insurance goes up he's no longer allowed
on our insurance because of that okay so
he's got like 24 points
um and then
because of that he's not going to be
able to afford to make the house the car
payment and the insurance what's his
name Debbie what's his name it is Jim
Jim okay I got I got a plan for Jim and
you Debbie you ready
yes I'd sell the car today
for 18. I need to grab three thousand
dollars left
I would give it to Jim if you guys are
in a good position no no it'll be turned
around we're gonna owe more than we can
get out of it you said you said it was
worth 18 and you owe 15. I paid 18. oh
you paid 18. what's worth what's it
worth you think
one of the dealers said they'd give us
like 10. okay I think if we sold it out
right okay I might be able to get more
all right so Jim isn't going to like my
my plan as I continue down this road but
I like it Rachel Debbie get rid of it
Debbie and you're gonna take a small
loan of five thousand dollars you know
what we call that Debbie around here
stupid tax
and we've all done it
we've all been in positions where we
think why did I do that why did I
co-sign and now my name she just thought
she was being a good mom she was just
she just thought she was doing the the
motherly thing and so Jim Jim is 21 is
he and he's living at home and that's
you know I'm not gonna rag on that but
but Jim is 21 and he's gonna have to
learn I have a long distance girlfriend
I have to now figure out my insurance is
up because I drove fast and got multiple
speeding tickets I have lost my license
my insurance is up Debbie this is not
your problem nope Jim has a lot of
problems does it but Debbie doesn't
Debbie has a 5 000 problem that you're
gonna have to just pay but I would I
would just I I just he's he's got to
learn and it's this isn't like a tough
love like but for you Debbie I'm looking
out for you because I'm like man you
could you know you again good Hearts
like you said Jade that the intention
was good but Debbie I want you guys I
want you to be in a position that you
are being wise with your money and this
and this isn't this isn't wise in fact
what's the scripture about co-signing
Jade to paraphrase to paraphrase the
scriptures it says that a person who
co-signs is stupid we're not calling you
stupid Debbie the Bible did no I'm just
kidding but it is saying the act of
doing that because you never know what's
going to happen and this is a this is a
very very good teaching point for
everybody listening right now um sorry
to put you on this pedestal Debbie but
it's a great teaching segment because
if there is any situation where somebody
would think I can co-sign for this
person they're not going to do me wrong
it is mother to son right yeah it's the
purest it's the purest relationship
right there purest of intent but Jim Jim
took you for a ride well and they
flipped it on her yeah that when they
pulled the credit they put her name on
there so I'm like I don't want you
liable Debbie with this car like I don't
trust that I don't I don't like it
that's right um but that's what they do
and you know what Debbie and and we have
to we're gonna have to go to a break
soon so I can't get all this information
from you but depending on
your situation Debbie if you are in a
financial position I'm thinking you're
not because you went and got a car loan
for your son and all of that but for
some reason if you did have
you know some money to spare after this
debt is cleaned up and you want to help
Jim out and say hey Jim I will match you
for your car you know you save 3 000 and
I and I will help you with 3 000 to get
you a six thousand you know like yeah if
there's ways to help without enabling
that's true and so if there is a type of
plan like that you want to do you can
but I want you Debbie in a solid
Financial Foundation meaning all of your
debts paid off including this new five
thousand dollar loan that you're going
to have after the car is sold you have
an emergency fund in place like you are
set up Debbie Jim is 21 he has his whole
life to figure this he sure does and and
you know what I mean and you're and
you're the mom so you're in the middle
and of the of the age range so it's like
I want you in a good position for
retirement yes and thank you large so
again it's uh it was out of a good place
it was out of a Mom's heart and it just
it was the word it's this is what
happens though the worst happens people
think it's gonna be fine yeah and then
it happens so Debbie I'm so sorry Coast
signing is the worst yeah don't do it we
weren't calling Debbie stupid but the
Bible does say that it is stupid to sign
Assurance or to co-sign for someone else
can I tell you guys a secret live on air
when I was dating Sam yes I quote and
and big quotes needed a new car yeah she
did I drove a Ford Taurus uh that had
lots of special features the heat didn't
work like and Sam was like you need a
new car he took me and I have of course
had terrible credit he co-signed for my
car the dumbest thing ever we were not
even engaged so let me tell you I know
something because here's the thing if
you're co-signing it means that that
person cannot get they can't get the
loan themselves which means the bank
knows they ain't got no money the bank
knows they can't be trusted yeah that's
the whole point of co-signing so think
about that for a minute you're putting
your neck on the line for something that
and in Banks they would love to give you
money that's right they're right there
for you man they'll give money to
they'll get money to anybody and if they
won't give money to this person that is
saying something like that's right red
flag to not sign for them so if we're
calling Debbie stupid I'm calling myself
stupid and I'm coming stupid at all I'm
just saying the scriptures got us on
lock on the the scripture put us in a
headlock on this one don't co-sign the
loan now and I love what Rachel said
because when my kids get older and they
get to driving age the plan is to buy
cars in cash yes you know yeah they're
gonna wreck them anyway I know they're
gonna get dinged up they're gonna get
scratched up yes I for sure would never
a brand new car no for well for a 16
year old no no no no but don't you
remember not until no yes in high school
people would come rolling through with
brand new cars yes yes they would oh yes
they would don't do it no not worth it
yeah the car thing it is uh
oh it's the piece of debt that I'm like
man the car loan borrowing money on
something going down in value all of it
but yes do not do it thanks for calling
Debbie it was a great call it's
something that we can all all learn from
we've all done stupid things the point
is that we learn from it and because we
took that call somebody is going to
avoid the Perils of co-signing